So there's only one really important and
interesting thing about this
equation and here it is.
Notice the Z value of the point.
So this is written in a funny way,
right?
This is Z of x, y.
What does that mean?
That means, if I'm at some point x,
y, remember that's a ray in space.
Right?
Z in the,
in accordance to my camera
is the depth of that point.
You'll notice that this thing is made up
of two terms, the A term and the B term.
The A term has the translation in it.
The B term has the rotation in it.
The depth is only in the A term,
the translation term.
Why?
Think about motion that happens.
If you remember, a projective
camera just has rays out in space.
And you can think of the rays as
going out till they hit something and
they stop, okay?
Now, if I rotate those rays.
In fact, maybe I can draw this.
So here's my point and
here's a whole bunch of rays.
So let's suppose here's my image
plane for frame one, okay?
If I rotate some angle, so
my image plane will now be there.
So before this ray was hitting
at that point on the plane and
now it's hitting at this
point on the plane.
So, if before it was in the middle,
now it's to the right-hand side.
Okay, fine.
Notice I didn't tell you how far the
rays went, because as the image plane
rotates and it cuts through the rays,
it doesn't matter how far the rays go.
So the depth has no impact on the amount
of motion that you see as you rotate,
but if I translate
the depth matters a lot.
Remember, the whole
thing about the moon?
Right?
That the moon seems to follow you?
And we're going to
demonstrate this right now.
So now get out your rulers
on the screen, right?
I'm going to take a step to the right,
like that.
Okay?
So the amount of motion that you
saw is whatever it is, all right?
Now, I take the same size step.
Megan, did I move in more of the field?
Did I move much further across the field
than I did when I was in the back?
Megan's going yes.
In other words, the amount of motion you
get, this is called motion parallax.
It is a function of the depth.
So that really dorky demonstration
is why the Z value is
only in the term that has
the translation component.
If you don't translate,
the depth doesn't matter in
terms of how much things move.
That's why we talked about when
you build panoramas from rotation,
I can just map the planes.
I can map the, the rays, because it
didn't matter what the depth was.
This is the general motion model.
I, I hope this was not too pedantic.
I like tying back the stuff we're doing
now with the, the stuff we did before.